[Music]
hi mystery recap here today i am going
to explain a japanese comedy drama film
called when i get home my wife always
pretends to be dead spoilers ahead watch
out and take care
june kagami is a regular office worker
living in tokyo with his wife chi kagami
jun believes that if a marriage lasts
for more than three years without much
hardship the couple is made for each
other his first marriage ended after
three years so before marrying chi the
two had made an agreement to renew their
marriage contract after their third
anniversary if they feel like they can
no longer be together they will simply
walk out of each other's lives currently
the pair's third marriage anniversary is
approaching and june is nervous about
how their future will play out while
thinking about such things he returns
home from work he rings the doorbell but
no one answers it is quite unusual
because chi always welcomes him at the
door june uses the spare key to get
inside and is met with a horrifying
sight she is lying limp on the floor
with blood dripping from her mouth he
falls beside her and tries to wake her
up but to no avail in this moment of
panic june remembers all the good times
he has shared with his wife on their
wedding day she had asked him not to die
before her so she wouldn't have to live
without him a few seconds later june
comes back to his senses and composes
himself he tries calling for an
ambulance when suddenly she grabs his
legs revealing that it was just a prank
as jun looks at her in shock she asks
him if he is surprised and giggles when
he doesn't reply she simply asks him to
come to the kitchen for dinner after
june has come out of his shocked state
he jokes about chi using ketchup as fake
blood the couple laughs as she mocks
jun's reaction to the prank for the rest
of the dinner their mood is happy and
lightened the following morning she asks
for a kiss before june leaves for work
he tells her they are not newlyweds
anymore so it is just cringe she however
doesn't share his views she hugs him
tightly claiming that they never know
what will happen during the day so this
might be their last goodbye on his way
out june drops off the garbage bag into
the bins a cleaning lady goes through
them and sees the bloodied clothes from
yesterday she starts to believe june is
doing something sketchy in his apartment
in the office june tells his co-worker
sano about the prank she pulled on him
yesterday ceno compliments chi for
putting effort to be funny and wishes
his wife was less serious i'm with sano
i wish my wife would occasionally trick
me into thinking she's dead traumatizing
me for life
june thinks that she is testing to see
if he still loves her so it would be
easier to decide if she wants to stay
with him even after three years later in
the evening she is cooking dinner when
she gets a text from june saying that he
is returning home she smiles
mischievously at the text ready for her
next prank some minutes later june walks
in and sees his wife lying on the floor
with her head inside a realistic
alligator's mouth she is pretending to
be eaten by the animal june plays along
and pulls her out of its mouth to save
her she dramatically thanks her husband
for saving her life and says that they
should eat dinner now following that she
continues to play dead every day getting
more creative with each prank one day
she pretends to be a maid who died after
being caught in a conflict following
that she is a trapped soldier shot by
the enemies but the one that impresses
june the most is when she pretends to be
shot by an arrow through her head he
complements the creativity although he's
getting more and more bothered by the
pranks as time passes june cannot
decipher why she is doing them and with
the third anniversary approaching it
worries him even more
one day he is dumping the garbage again
which now mostly contains props that she
uses to pretend to be dead the cleaning
lady goes through the bag and finds a
bloodied knife she makes a scene in
front of everyone and calms down only
when june explains to her that the blood
is ketchup he again expresses his
uneasiness to his coworker ceno who
suggests he sent chi to her parents home
for a few days yeah let her give her
father a heart attack instead as they
talk june begins to tell him how he
first met chi and got to know her he was
in shizuaka for a business meeting but
he missed his bus back home she saw him
running behind it and invited him to her
father's restaurant she was a pretty
young girl but her cheerful personality
is what caught jun's eyes her mother had
passed away when she was only five but
she never let her sadness show in front
of people before leaving she had told
him her wish was to eat a dessert from
mont saint claire in tokyo and he
invited her to the city some time later
sano is pleasantly surprised by the
unique love story that day june returns
home to see chi has turned herself into
an old soldier from the medieval period
who died in the war she has used several
arrows because june had praised her the
last time he plays along and pretends to
be sad about her death but he doesn't
have to pretend anymore when he sees the
price tag on the costume she is wearing
the next day he tells santa that he is
going to play along with the pranks to
see if she will stop doing them hence
when he returns home and sees her being
abducted by fake aliens he puts on the
best performance of his life and fights
them however this doesn't stop chi
instead she prepares him an elaborate
skit asking him to perform better one
time she pretends to be a dead vampire
who has to be revived by pulling out the
dagger in her chest june does as the
skit says and gets bitten by her in the
process following that she pretends to
be juliet who needs romeo's help to be
revived from the dead similar to the
last time june acts like he is mourning
and brings her back to life at work he
cannot focus anymore and is almost
scared to return home sono sympathizes
with his work friend to make him avoid
the pranks for just a day he invites the
couple to dinner with his wife they all
meet at a restaurant at the end of the
day sano's wife yumiko also joins them
while talking she is asked why she
decided to marry jun a flashback shows
us that after meeting at the restaurant
the pair met in tokyo as well june takes
chi to the cafe she always wanted to
visit while walking through the streets
of tokyo she runs after a street vendor
that sells her favorite wafer cake june
bolts behind her and finally gets to the
vendor since he only has one cake left
they share it she gives him the bigger
piece but june asks her to have the
bigger one this was when she fell in
love with him back in the present while
returning home june falls in love with
his wife again they look at the moon and
appreciate its beauty together one day
on his way home june notices an
advertisement for a vacancy at a local
laundry place he thinks if she starts
working she will have less time for the
pranks so he brings the paper home get a
job honey stop pretending to be dead she
welcomes him dressed as an egyptian
princess inside a coffin after the
dramatic encounter they simply walk to
the kitchen for dinner june tells her
about the vacancy and urges her to apply
she is skeptical at first but she agrees
to do it anyway starting the next day
she works at the laundry shop owned by
an old man yet it doesn't stop her from
executing the pranks she pretends to be
killed by a bank robber that evening
having had enough june tells her that he
is tired of seeing her play dead the
next day chi goes on a date with sana's
wife yumiko and finds out she has been
trying to get pregnant for six years but
hasn't been successful the couple's
relationship is rocky because of this
but she's kind words make yumiko feel
better june brings his wife flowers and
her favorite cake but when he enters the
apartment he sees her pretending to be a
ghost rising from her grave since he
asked her not to play dead she pretended
to be a ghost who is already dead clever
chi she hugs him for the cake and cooks
him something good for dinner on the
weekend she pretends to be a robot but
june forcefully makes her take the mask
off following that he notices a letter
from his former wife asking him to meet
her someday the pair invites sano and
his wife to dinner one day yumiko
notices the alligator toy in the room
and is fascinated by it it turns out
that she is very much into alligators
which surprises even her husband
everything goes well until sano mentions
that men need time off from their wives
this upsets yumiko and she gets into an
argument with sano to make her feel
better she offers her the alligator if
she wins an arm wrestling match against
her yumiko wins because she used to
train at karate she happily takes the
alligator home sano feels bad because he
didn't know his wife's interests even
after being married for six years the
following day june comes home to see chi
has turned herself into a person from
2050 for the first few minutes he plays
along and asks her questions about the
future but then he inquires what he has
to do for her to stop pulling these
pranks she goes silent and starts to
calculate the average number of days
they will spend together in the future
even when he persists she doesn't answer
his question some days later yumiko
tells chi that she and sano have decided
to separate she thanks chi for making
her feel appreciated because of her the
couple was able to talk about their
feelings to each other somewhere else
june and sano go to a restaurant to talk
about the matter sano claims that the
divorce is a good decision for both of
them because yumiko deserves a more
attentive partner june also reveals that
his ex-wife once disappeared for two
weeks and came back saying she wanted a
divorce by the end of the night he is
very drunk so she picks him up the
following day they get the news about
chi's father being in the hospital due
to a heart attack they quickly rush to
her hometown and meet her father who has
thankfully been saved she meets him but
cannot control her tears afterward when
she is not in the room her father tells
june that she hasn't cried since her
mother's death he also mentions that one
night after her mother died she saw him
crying while looking at her picture
starting the next day she began to hide
around the house when he returned from
work at first her father thought it was
troublesome and weird but as time went
on the simple activity of her hiding
helped him get over his wife's death
because he was occupied june realizes
that he too has been more involved in
their relationship since she started to
play dead he registers that her pranks
are not a result of her being
unsatisfied but she just wanted to feel
closer to him and keep him entertained
later the two go to the park where june
proposed to her they spend the rest of
their day talking to each other about
different things the pair returns to
tokyo after a few days she comes back
home after work to see june lying on the
floor with blood spewing from his mouth
she freaks out and tries to wake him up
but soon realizes he is also pulling a
prank the movie ends as june suggests
they have dinner but she is too mad at
him for scaring her like that subscribe
for more videos like this turn on
notifications and leave a like to help
the channel out thank you for watching